in the lobby of Ramsey solutions will
and alley are with us is it Ali is that
correct
yes sir welcome you guys good to have
you where you from Orlando Florida
awesome well welcome to Nashville and
you're here to do your debt-free scream
yes sir
very cool how much have you paid off
forty three thousand dollars love it and
how long did that take you 22 months
good job and your range of income during
that two years we started at 75 and are
at about 122 good for you guys nice
raises what do y'all do for a living I'm
a civil engineer and I am a full-time
mom and a part-time waitress very good
so how did you get a $50,000 raise in
two years what happened she went back to
work and I got a new job auto Oh cut a
little bit all right cool very nice what
kind of debt was the forty three
thousand well it was our oldest was born
medical payments and in student loans
so the normal alright just normal stuff
just bopping along and starting to pile
up so how many kids have you got we have
one we have Aubree and we actually have
one on the way
oh very good fun good and hold us Aubree
she's - oh good okay so we had to pay
for her so she didn't get repo'd and
then we got then we got Sallie Mae to
get her fiction notice get the old woman
out of the house right that's right very
cool so what happened twenty-two months
ago that kind of woke you up and said
hey we got clean this up well Aubrey was
born we were starting to get the medical
bills in and I looked at Allie and I
said this is just this is ridiculous we
got to do something about this and we
just wanted out freedom yeah wanting the
freedom and that combined with the
student loan payments coming out it's
just like we got to get this out of our
lives so very cool so what did you do
next once you said that well we actually
had already planned a road trip and
someone had given us Financial Peace
University the audio book the CD we
listened to that and that was our answer
I mean we heard that and we looked at
each other and we knew that that's
you're gonna do okay so we started right
away as soon as we you know finished the
CDs yeah once you get weird enough that
you listen to a financial program on
your vacation road trip that's when
you're ready to change that's because
that's like that's to most people that'd
be a root canal now the good news is
Financial Peace University is pretty
entertaining but but that's still that's
pretty hardcore right there man you trap
yourself in the car and force-feed four
hours on in and now we go back at home
and do this stuff huh we couldn't turn
it off I mean I be honest we started it
and we had about a 10-hour Drive and
just couldn't turn it off Wow it's well
worth it well thank you that's very kind
awesome awesome I'm so proud of you so
now that you've done it you paid off
forty three thousand dollars now that
you did that people ask how did you do
that what do you tell the secrets to
getting out of debt are I think you have
to definitely work together as a team
mm-hmm and just keep going forward
hard mm-hmm and put your head down and
just do it and know that in the future
it will pay off mm-hmm for me it's the
envelopes doing the envelope system
really opened your eyes to where all
your cash is going like you say it is a
lot more of a sting when you're paying
cash with things rather than a card so
if we hadn't done the envelopes I don't
think we would have been here okay very
cool good so how long have you guys been
married three years three years so you
went one year and then baby is born and
here we go that's right yeah and so
you've had two years a game on doing
this and so how does it feel now that
you don't have any payments amazing just
nothing on the Shorter's just we can
live and we're able to come to Nashville
and see you and meet you and do this and
it's great it's it's really cool to see
something come in your bank account know
that well I get to choose where this
goes it's not someone else telling me
where it goes yeah so it changes
everything that's really good really
good well congratulations you two very
proud of you thank well done you got to
feel great very good will an ally so
we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired number one
bestseller signed by mr. Chris himself
that's the next
chapter in your financial success you go
now from living like no one else now you
can live and give like no one else
builds your wealth and all those kinds
of things so I get you into a great
position so very well alright so as Ally
know what's going on do you think Aubrey
I'm sorry
your ally I'm sorry Ally doesn't know
what's gonna I get mixed up to know
that's worse than me getting a mixed up
she'll figure it out soon enough okay
very cool all right will and Ally and
Aubrey $43,000 paid off in 22 months
making 75 to 122 count it down let's
there a debt free scream well done love
it guys way to go you two that is
awesome that beautiful little girl
realized her whole life has changed
because her parents decided to take
control of their lives there's something
so empowering about being in charge of
your money there's something so
emotionally whole about your life when
you're in charge of your money instead
of your money telling you how screwed up
your life is all the time
there's taking control just grab the
thing around the neck and choke it kill
it kill it
I'm gonna win you got a win man
you gotta you gotta bust it it's hard
but it is worth it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in economy